ready to open this up yeah you ready
yeah
all right so we open up this envelope
right there in the airport and I hate
planning vacations
I do enjoy planning vacations I don't
like having to find a hotel I don't like
having to find flights I find to be
stressful I just I like knowing where
I'm going I like knowing how I'm getting
there I like to time things I like to be
punctual so I started to think what if
Rob and I took a vacation where we have
no control over anything not even the
destination I decided we would take a
trip where we would one have no idea
where we were going to have to go to any
restaurant or attraction that was
suggested to us and three only order
items that were recommended so for the
first item on that checklist I decided
to book our trip using a company that
specializes in mystery vacations called
pack up and go I went and filled out a
questionnaire just listing all of our
interests so they could match us to the
perfect destination craft beer and
breweries always veneers in wine bars
yes cocktail bars yes so about seven
days before we're scheduled to depart we
receive an email giving us just a few
details about where we're going it's
gonna be mid 70s and sunny which could
be anywhere where could we be going I
have no idea so about two days before
our departure I receive in Priority Mail
a big envelope and I was at this point I
started being really excited about our
trip
feels like Denver there's that son where
am i hoping it's it's open it'd be great
if it was the city that we've never been
to before
yeah I have a feeling it's Denver for
some reason it may be it could be Idaho
Sun Valley is pretty cool and I think
the weather might be right thank you
very much ready to uh jopen this out
yeah
you ready all right so we open up this
envelope right there in the airport and
Denver Colorado and I was pretty happy
we were gone Denver right Chris oh here
we go Christian and Rob we are so
excited to have planned this weekend
getaway for you thanks for trusting us
we think that based on your interest in
good food and drinks museums and the
outdoors you guys are going to have a
blast in Denver have a fantastic trip
and happy travels
[Music]
we're on the plane we know we're going
to Denver Colorado I'm a trade table and
I started making an itinerary of the
places that I thought maybe out of what
pack up and go gave us we would want to
hit up we promised ourselves we would
hit up as many as we could unless we met
somebody who recommended you check out
someplace else Denver here we are so one
of the first people we met in Denver
reminded us that recreational marijuana
is legal in Colorado and he recommended
that we check out a dispensary walking
past and it's like there is common as to
7-eleven or Starbucks here in New York
unfortunately there's no footage though
because they don't allow cameras inside
it's a very private experience okay so
we are now on our way to a restaurant
called guard and grace garden grace was
a recommendation from pack up and go
they actually booked a reservation for
us I cannot speak highly enough about
this place as per the rules we had to
ask the waiter for his suggestions and
every single dish that he recommended in
we ate it just smashed it knocked it out
of the park it was one of the best meals
I've ever had
at a restaurant and I really think it
was in part to just listening to this
guy that knows the menu the next morning
we ate at a popular breakfast spot that
we had heard about and there a waitress
recommended we check out through the
breweries that are in that area we
borrow a bike from our hotel and
literally hit up everyone she mentioned
all right so we are on our way now to
the first of our Brewing Company bike
crawl these are all Wynkoop
what what do you recommend if a
bartender recommended a beer we drank it
and if someone suggested a different
brewery
then we went there West Coast IPA hoppy
orange pith and bitter an Indian Pale
Ale
not so much
second seed died the best part about
Denver hands down was a suggestion from
pack up and go they recommended we go to
Red Rocks at 5:30 in the morning we have
to jump in an uber travel 45 minutes
into the start of the Rocky Mountains
and we're going to the Red Rock National
Park to watch the Sun Rise the video
doesn't really do justice to what it
looked like just seeing those colors
makes the Red Rocks that were
surrounding us it was the most beautiful
moments of the entire trip everything
you could ask for is sitting there
waiting for that stuff to come up
overlooking Denver and after sunrise we
met somebody who recommended that we do
one of the longer hiking trails that's
in that area and we did it although we
weren't quite dressed appropriately for
to be honest like something I learned
about myself on this trip like it is
really nice to embrace and big U&E
sometimes just kind of go with the flow
damn like that's a really fantastic way
to live life if I could just sort of
blow that out a little bit and practice
that in general overall I wish I could
only go on mystery of invasions
yeah there's there is so much power in
letting someone else plan things for you
[Music]